la asesora política del primer ministro
británico alegras platón dimitió este
miércoles entre lágrimas su anuncio se
dio tras la filtración del vídeo en el
que se burla de la fiesta de navidad que
supuestamente tuvo lugar el año pasado
cuando regían en el país estrictas
restricciones por la pandemia
mis comentarios parecían hacer que las
reglas fueran menos importantes reglas
que la gente hacía todo lo posible por
cumplir esa nunca fue mi intención
lamentar estos comentarios por el resto
de mis días lo siento de verdad y esta
tarde ofrezco mi dimisión al primer
ministro
las imágenes en cuestión obtenidas por
tn fueron grabadas a mediados de
diciembre del 2020 cuando gran parte del
reino unido está bajo confinamiento y se
prohíbe a la gente reunirse con sus
familias
nuer no fiesta era una cena compartida
esto está grabado en esta fiesta
ficticia era una reunión de negocios y
no había distanciamiento social en medio
del escándalo generado por el vídeo el
primer ministro se enfrentó a las
preguntas de los diputados y prometió
una investigación
pedir presión pido disculpas por la
impresión que se ha dado que el personal
de downing street se toma esto menos que
en serio yo mismo estoy asqueado y
furioso por eso funciones
el líder de la oposición laborista keir
starmer ha acusado a boris johnson y al
gobierno de mentir repetidamente al
público gamer stop document el primer
ministro y el gobierno se pasaron la
semana diciendo al público británico que
no había ninguna fiesta todas las
orientaciones se siguieron al pie de la
letra millones de personas piensan ahora
que el primer ministro los tomó por
tontos y que les mintió tienen razón no
la guaira hombre
el primer ministro anunció este
miércoles la activación del llamado plan
b que impone restricciones como el porte
de mascarillas uso de un pase sanitario
y el regreso del trabajo a distancia en
un esfuerzo por contener la variante un
micrón